so my first-ever computer vomity I think
it was my first ever one my first ever
computer for video was on digital images
and really what I was talking about was
how we represent an image in memory but
a little bit of that was about
multi-dimensional arrays because images
are multi-dimensional arrays now
obviously a lot of my research is around
deep learning we actually see
multi-dimensional arrays quite a lot in
deep learning and they can get four or
five or more dimensional depending on
what kind of data you're looking at and
so what I wanted to talk about today was
the kind of nifty way we represent these
in the computer because of course memory
is we don't represent memory in a
multi-dimensional array it's just linear
address space so how do we map from five
dimensions down to one very very quickly
so that we can perform all this very
very fast deep learning on it if you use
any kind of numerical library so for
example numpy or MATLAB or R or any of
the tensor libraries that tend to flow
or PI torch
they have multi-dimensional arrays in
them so pi stalks you call some
temptones tend to flow calls and tensors
and they are the kind of the building
block of your deep network they
represent the data that you're passing
around and these tensors are often quite
large and multiple they have multiple
dimensions so maybe five dimensions or
four dimensions it's quite common
because these are actually represented
in memory is a linear array we have to
decide how to actually index them quite
quickly and the whole point of these
libraries is they're really really fast
right no one's going to be able to train
a deep network if you're spending ages
copying array bits around and moving
things around it has to be super quick
let's start with a really basic
definition of a two-dimensional array
right which is kind of going back to our
first video and talking about an image
right so I'm going to talk about images
because that's why it's very most of my
time doing actually it doesn't really
matter what data you're representing by
it's just in a multi-dimensional array
so let's imagine that we have an image
which is currently grayscale right so
it's a little box and it has this is y
and this is X and let's say it's a
hundred pixels by 100 pixels quick
summon my head suggests to me that
there's probably 10,000 pixels in this
image and each one has some value now we
don't actually store in RAM 100 by a
hundred thousand
make sense we store one by 10,000 array
and we have to make sure that where we
want a specific pixel we jump to the
right point so what we need to define is
a few items so we're going to define a
size of the array right and that's going
to be 100 by 100 I'm starting on the
right will see later as I add more
dimensions I still have I'm gonna run
out of space and then we have an offset
which is going to be 0 now that offset
is where do we start in our memory of
space now you might change your set if
you're doing certain operations we're
not going to talk about them at the
moment so I'm just going to keep that at
0 and then we have our stride I
mentioned this in my original video what
we use is something called with stride
which is the width of a row of an image
bearing in mind any padding and that
depends on the file format the stride
represents how far we have to go in
memory to get to the next one of a
certain dimension right so in this case
to go from 1x to the next X it's just
one pixel across all right so that's
going to be a stride of one to get from
one row to the next row we have to go a
hundred pixels along and map round to
the next one and so that's going to be a
stride of 100 so suppose we want to find
the fourth row in this image what we
would do is we would do 4 times by the
wise stride and that will give us the
index into the fourth row in terms of
memory is just going along a long list
to the right point so this list is one
long list and we're jumping to the
correct position for that low and then
we can read the x-values off the way
I've written is here is kind of general
so we can add a dimension to this so
let's imagine we no longer have just one
grayscale channel we have three channels
for RG and B right now I'm going to
represent this as additional channels
forming another dimension at the back
here so this is our G and B so we have
three of these in this direction so this
is our sort of channel dimension you
could say it's Z but if we're going to
add more dimensions let's not run out of
letters too quickly so to do this what
we have to do is we have to add another
entry into our size and another entry
into our stride so to go from one row to
the next is moving 100 pixels but to go
from one image to the next or one
channel to the next is going to be a
hundred times 100 pixels which is 10,000
so that's our stride for this next event
along and the size in this dimension is
going to be three and that makes sense
obviously I've just added three
dimensions because I've added them
behind like this I sort of messed it up
I'm gonna have to reallocate memory and
this is going to sort of get reset as it
were so offset is still zero but our new
origin point is this one here and we're
moving both way I just think it's easier
to see them coming this way rather than
I mean this this powers point in the
wrong way but we won't dwell on it so Y
X and then either Zed or channel or
whatever it is you want so offset is
still zero so this is going to be here
all right so this is a very origin of
our data and as we move along in memory
we're going to go down through this
first image then we're going to go to
the next image we're going to go down
through this image and then to the next
image and down through this image all
the way to the end suppose we want to
find out what the index for some low in
the middle channel is what we have to do
is we have to do so this is the first
index into the channel so it's one times
ten thousand plus euro times 100 plus
your x times one and that will give you
the exact point in memory in linear
memory for the pixel on the second plane
we're gonna run out of space I tried not
to but it's going to happen right so
let's imagine we want to add another
dimension right so now we don't have a
XY image which has three channels we
have a number of XY images that have
three channels but they are all
represented in the same place in memory
they each have their location so all
gets will get some drawing going and
this is going to be the next one well
that's just bad and then I'm in this way
like this and it comes off the screen we
know what we will ignore this one
because it's off the page and we're not
going to be in a draw properly on it so
we're gonna start off set here now this
is our new offset but this is our
position in memory of the first pixel in
all of our data and this is the next
dimension going this way and then you've
got the channel dimension and then
you've got the X&Y dimensions going this
way we need bigger paper right for all
my dimensions I'm gonna have to add
another stride and another size in here
so this happens to be three as well so
we're going to add another size of three
to go through each of these dimensions
is 10,000 and there are three of them so
it's going to be 10,000 times three it's
30,000 we're going to need to jump
between each of these index
in this dimension so this is going to be
30,000 like this so now if we want to
jump to this one we go
0 1 2 in that dimension x 30,000 plus
whichever channel we want x 10,000 plus
the Y and the X and we can go right to
the exactly where we want but the thing
to remember is that this is always when
it's declared this way always just one
long line in memory now we can fiddle
about with a stride and the offset and
stuff and do clever things that'll be
pad to another time so we'll add another
dimension right so now in five
dimensions now I don't like to think I
don't know how to visualize five
dimensions I just think of it as or
groups of groups of groups you know
because that's how I see it in my mind
because that's just how it is in memory
so now we're going to add another one I
should have added a few interventions
that we were taking me less time to draw
maybe I can get this one more square
than the one before
still a little square right so now this
is our next dimension coming down this
way so this is now five dimensional now
I haven't got them for my stride but
this stride is going to be thirty
thousand times by another three which is
ninety thousand so I'm going to put 90 K
in here and the size is going to be two
in this dimension
alright and the offset is now this
position here all right which is the
beginning of all of our data I'm just
coming this direction that's why you
could add more dimensions in in sort of
a direction if you wanted to now so if I
want to go down in this dimension I'm
going to have to do 0 1 times by 90,000
plus 1 times 30,000 and so on and I can
jump straight to the exact position I
want in memory now this is actually
surprising it there's a few things about
this that make it very very quick the
first is that actually each plane of
data so each image channel is actually
contiguous in memory almost all the time
there are things you can do with offsets
and strides and so on to mess around
with that property but for the sake of
argument if this is contiguous in memory
copying to inform it very very quick
right doing operations on these channels
very very quick so you can say - let's
say some layer in a convolutional
Network you can say do me a matrix
multiplication on this little bit here
through all these channels and it will
go off and it will do that and it can
look in the correct place in memory
based on all of these values all right
so we don't have to copy that anywhere
else and process it we can just use this
thing and just look into it which is a
super neat way of looking into this kind
of size of data and you can have as many
it dimensions as you want it really
makes no difference it's just about how
many entries you have in the size and
the stride lists and basically which one
you multiply by what dimension and so on
yes that's exactly right it's unlikely
but you would use it to show even
brighter red because usually 255 would
mean as as red as you could get let's
say so you would just have a finer range
of colors in between